(cris des manifestants)
- Des milliers de Soudanais ont
de nouveau défié les autorités
en prenant la ru
(tirs)
Dans la capitale,
les forces de sécurité ont
repoussé la foule à coup
de gaz lacrymogène,
alors qu'elle s'approchait
du palais présidentiel.
(tirs)
Au moins deux manifestants
ont été tués lors des marches
qui se sont déroulées dans
plusieurs villes du pays.
Depuis le coup d'État
perpétré à la fin octobre,
une cinquantaine de personnes
sont mortes lors
manifestations qui se succèdent
pour réclamer le retour
d'un pouvoir civil
à la tête du Soudan.
"Nous manifestons pour la chute
du pouvoir militaire", dit-elle.
"Il faut en finir avec les
militaires au pouvoir",
renchérit ce manifestant.
La fragile transition
démocratique qui s'était amorcée
en 2019 après la chute du
dictateur soudan
el-Bechir a brusquement pris
fin le 25 octobre dernier.
L'armée a décrété
l'état d'urgence
et limogé le gouvernement.
D'abord arrêté, le premier
ministre qui était en poste
a été rétabi dans ses fonctions
devant les pressions
internationales, à l'issue d'une
entente avec les militaires.
Incapable de former
un gouvernement ion,
il a finalement annoncé sa
décision aujourd'hui dans un
discours télévisé.
"J'ai fait de mon mieux pour
empêcher le pays de glisser
vers la catastrophe", dit-
Il souhaite maintenant passer
le flambeau à quelqu'un d'autre.
Pour le moment, le pouvoir
reste donc concentré dans les
mains de l'armée et du généralél
Abdel Fattah al-Burhan.
L'incertitude vient encore
d'augmenter d'un cran.
Ici Olivier Bachand,